here's a slightly more advanced or
involved simple linear equation and say
solve 28 over three is equal to
one-third plus X and it's a little bit
more involved because now we have
fractions over here the 28 over three
and the one-third so let me just rewrite
it they're telling us the 28 over three
is equal to one-third plus X so like
always we want to isolate our variable
in this case our variable is X on one
side of the equation I only have the X
sitting on the right hand side and so we
can completely isolate it if we can get
rid of this one-third right over here
and as you can imagine the best way to
get rid of that one-third is to subtract
1/3 from the right hand side but I can't
just subtract it from the what from the
right hand side then that would change
the Equality this thing it's telling me
is equal to this whole expression right
over here if I subtract 1/3 from only
one side of it I have to do the other
side as well in order for the Equality
to be hold if I did it from just one
side it wouldn't hold so I'm going to
subtract the same quantity from both
sides so that they're still going to be
equal so the left-hand side 28 over 3
minus 1/3 I can write over here it might
be 2 in a format that you're more
familiar with we have the same
denominator that is the same thing as 27
over 3 which is actually the same thing
as 9 so 28 over 3 minus one third is 27
over 3 which is the same thing as 9 and
then on the right hand side and we have
this equal the same equal sign right
over there 1/3 minus 1/3 these guys
cancel out and we are just left with an
X so we're done we've solved for X X is
equal to 9 and now we can verify that by
substituting back into this original
equation so let me rewrite the original
equation 28 over three needs to be equal
to 1/3 plus and we just solved for X so
instead of an X I can write instead of
an X I can write a 9 let's see if this
really is the case so to add 1/3 plus 9
we need to find a common denominator and
3 will work so 9 is the same thing as 27
over 3 and
and 1/3 plus 27 over 3 is 1 plus 27 over
3 1 plus 27 over 3 which is equal to 28
over 3 so it works 28 over 3 is equal to
28 over 3